it is my pleasure to introduce dr gary
trouble
dr trouble earned his bs in
environmental science with an emphasis
on microbiology at the university of
arizona and worked for the usda for two
years researching how to use fungi as a
biocontrol on crops instead of
pesticides
he then did an ms in environmental
science and health at the university of
nevada reno in the desert research
institute where he researched active
bacteria inhabiting the sub-zero
temperature like veda brine in
antarctica
gary finished his studies by earning a
phd in microbiology at the ohio state
university where he characterized
viruses and soils underlying with
permafrost and their roles in ecosystem
carbon processing
gary did his post doc at lawrence
livermore national laboratory in 2018
where he used stable isotope probing
combined with metagenomics and
vararomics to track microbial and viral
activity and substrate utilization in
various soils
gary is currently a staff scientist at
the lawrence livermore national
laboratory where he continues to use
metaomics combined with other techniques
for example isotope probing to
characterize viruses microbes and virus
microdynamics
so please join me in welcoming dr gary
trouble
hi everyone can you hear me
yes we can hear you
great
so this is such a cool time to go that
way graham that was such a such a good
talk and i knew i was going to be going
after you such a great speaker
um i think that that was perfect oh
right before my talk because it really
has this take a step back you think
about
what are what are we doing for
astrobiology what are our goals what do
we need to think about i think
a lot of us get bogged down in what
astral ball just has to be
and you know as as you heard in my
background the way i got into
astrobiology is different than other
ways that people get natural biology and
i would arguably say an astrobiologist
to somebody that questions life like
what are we doing why are we here what
what is life all about
i think one of my favorite quotes is
from a nasa
uh
nasa astrobiology institute poster where
for astrobiology it says
what is life where is life and how do we
find it and that that's really what it's
all about there's no direct path that
you have to take to become an
astrobiologist
so here i'm going to give you
kind of some vignettes of work that i've
been doing
ways that i'm pushing the boundary to
really detect and look at life
i arguably think viruses are alive at
some points we have our working
definition of life but there's no set
definition
but
for instance when a virus infects a host
it
its metabolism and the host only does
what the virus wants it to do so is it
the host that's alive or is it the virus
that's alive
so i chose soils to go into because
they're the most diverse ecosystem and
to really look at detecting our limits
for life we need to be looking in soil
ecosystems um so i'll have some shout
outs at the end for some astrobiology
and astrovirology endeavors that i've
done but i want you to take some time to
really
learn about viruses and viruses and
soils and please ask questions if you
have any at the end
so the first thing i want to point out
is that
metagenomics and metabolic processes
these are metatronomics meta
transcriptomics meta proteomics and
metabolomics there's so many out there
have really revolutionized how we look
at viruses and just microbiology in
general
um here's a figure i took from a paper
from by simon root in 2019
where
in blue and green you can kind of see
our isolates of viruses that we just
accumulated over time but in just such a
short span of time we've shot up the
number of viral population genomes that
we've gotten in databases so quickly
and kind of
help you understand that what a meta
genome is the way we're looking at
viruses without needing to cultivate
them
is that we're taking a sample like soil
and we're extracting all the nucleic
acids so for metagenome this would be
all the dna from the soil and we're
sequencing it then we're reconstructing
all these genomes
we're also reconstructing the variants
that go along with these genomes so we
like to call it population genomes
so this is what i've been pushing is
really looking at viruses from soils
using metagenomics primarily
so until recently if you looked at viral
studies
they haven't really been in soils um we
had some of our first studies in the
oceans and then we had everyone caring
about human viruses taken off and
there's nothing wrong with that i like
human viruses but i specifically focus
on viruses that infect microbes
especially bacteria and we call these
bacterophage so these viruses are host
specific they can only infect bacteria
as we know
but there's so much that they can do in
the environment and this is what i'm
exploring and they have the largest
diversity of any viruses out there
so what i've done with my time now at ll
not lawrence livermore national lab is
really push
soil viromics a study of just focusing
at the virus comportment
of
viruses in the soil so we've been
pushing the studies up there
so the problem
why am i shooting for soils and how does
soils help with our detection of life
when we take a metagenome we sequence
all the dna from soil
less than two percent of our data we
like to call this assembled reads
actually go to viral sequences
less than two percent so we're not
really seeing viruses in our main way in
which we're detecting viruses
and the reason for this is if you look
at soil i have this small area that i
have zoomed in for you there's so much
going on in soils you have your plants
your roots the rises here it's so rich
you have your macrophage your meso5 the
microphone then if you zoom in then you
get at your micro do you have your
bacteria archaea
and if you zoom in even further now you
can see the viruses
so when we're taking this dna we're
taking all of this dna and so the
viruses
yes they're highly abundant they're the
most abundant biological entity out
there but they have these small genomes
that get swamped by these large genomes
so i've worked for my phd and since on
really being able to get as much
information we can from the tools that
we have and then bringing tools together
to increase the detection
so the first thing i'm going to talk to
you about is when i use from a
postdoctor now is stable isotope probing
to really look at microbes and viruses
in ecosystems but specifically soils so
if we look at microbes that we have
bacteria here
they can exist in many different
metabolic states when they're in soil or
any environment i'm just going to keep
saying soil
but the majority of them are actually
dormant or deceased and when we take all
this dna we're looking at this whole
community so we're actually seeing who's
who's contributing we're seeing all the
members it's kind of if we looked at the
human population 16 everyone alive now
we saw everyone who was ever on the
earth and
for different research questions we kind
of care about what's going on now or
who's contributing right now
in order to bypass this i'm going to
talk to you about two different diff
versions of isotopes that i use with
compounds to look at viruses
so the first one we call heavy water so
you have traditional water which is h2
around 16 now that's the most abundant
isotope of oxygen but we can change that
oxygen isotope to 18-0 this is enriching
it this is less abundant so when we add
this
any organism that uses water which is
everything that's active because water
is a universal substrate for life it's
going to incorporate this heavier oxygen
into its dna or rna so we can actually
pull that out and we know who's using
the water so we know who is active so
with heavy water we're going to label
all active organisms and the viruses
that infect them
another experiment i'm going to talk
about is where we can use specific
substrates to target certain parts of
the community so instead of all
organisms in this study i mean used in
rich plant biomass this is where we grow
plants with 13 co2 so the plants will
take up the co2 for photosynthesis
they'll be enriched with 13c carbon so
the whole plant is now 13th street c
labeled so any organism that's munching
away and breaking down that carbon
is going to become labeled so i'm going
to specifically look at the organisms
that are responsible for degrading the
plant biomass
once we have that organism labeled we
then can extract its dna and then we can
do ultrasonification to separate the dna
physically separating the dna based on
its density so in these tubes here we
have our dormant deceased or our
non-degrading 13c plant biomass dna up
towards the top and then the one that's
enriched with the 13c or the 180 is more
dense so we can physically separate it
we can pull them out separately and we
can sequence them separately so this is
helpful because now we can sequence who
is active and who's contributing but
also for comparative reasons we also
know who else is there and the reason is
when we sample an environment we're
taking a snapshot in time so just
because something's active right now
doesn't mean it's necessarily active
later and we're still trying to figure
out this time scale this temporal
sampling to really understand how the
environment and the dynamics are
changing it could be i sample something
now and then a minute later those are no
longer active this is what we're really
trying to figure out so we take both and
then we can compare
also by looking at both we get this nice
genetic catalog of everything that's
possible in the environment and this can
help other fields such as biotechnology
or looking at the health of the soil
possibly
okay so going into my first paper that i
want to talk about so this is something
that we published last year and it was
exciting work
it kind of brought me back to my phd
work where i was working on viruses and
permafrost which is frozen ground so
here we looked at permafrost which is
groundless frozen for two or more
consecutive years in alaska
and what happens is every year the
permafrost has an active layer that
seasonally thaws and the microbes become
active and then during the winter
freezes back up now it's currently
thought that all the carbon that's
leaving the soil you know leading to
climate change and global warming is for
microbes coming from the summer that's
when they're active that's when there
were spiraling releasing co2
but there's been mounting evidence to
suggest that co2 is leaving during the
winter as well so we really wanted to
look at this so we went and we sampled
this peat which is this highly organic
nutritious soil
that just hangs around because it's so
cold and the conditions aren't right for
microbes to break it down readily
so we took this pea and we simulated
winter conditions so we brought it down
to below freezing we made it anoxic so
there's no oxygen and we incubated it
for a full year and we sampled at a half
year and then at the end of the full
year
from this we physically extracted the
dna and separated it and then we
sequenced 23 metagenomes
during this time we also measured carbon
dioxide being produced in these bottles
all right so the key takeaways of what
happened here
we realized that there were active
viruses and bacteria in the subfreezing
anoxic permafrost soils
and that when we compare who is active
to who is not active the communities
were very different so in this figure we
have these larger pills which are
bacteria and then we have these hexagons
which represent viruses if they have
numbers and they're larger they were
active if they're smaller they were
inactive now they don't show you their
abundance but if you look at the pink
ones on the bottom typically when we
look at these permafrost oils these are
arctan bacteria these are the most
abundant organisms they just dominate
and if you look most of them actually
were not active
and the ones that were active were our
green ones and our yellow ones so these
are our firm cubes and our bacteria
deities and what's crazy about this is
if we had just taken a traditional
metagenome we would have never looked at
these organisms their abundance is so
much lower we would have ignored them
but they're actually who is there and
who's active so we would have missed the
important part of our research so by
adding the stabilized steel probing with
our metagenomics we got to see this
we also got to see that while only a
small portion of the bacterial community
was active
a large portion of our viral activity
was active over 70 percent
looking into the metabolism of these
bacteria we saw that they had the
capabilities for fermentation and for
breaking down carbon
okay
so we also know that they were inspired
and produced too so we physically showed
that respiration was occurring over
winter so this makes us rethink how we
think of the activities of organisms in
different environments that in these
subfreezing environments there is carbon
dioxide coming from they are active
we were able to link a third of these
active viruses to host and we looked at
their genes the viruses actually carried
these genes that when they infect the
host they can make the host use these
genes
and it can help the host scavenge
nutrients to help survive the winter or
possibly help them break down other
plant biomass
another thing as we saw is that as the
bacterial community shifted over the
year the viral community shifted towards
the bacterial community so we know from
previous research that viruses will lyse
their host and kind of kill the winter
hypothesis so they maintain diversity by
you have one population that shoots up
and the viruses kill it and control it
and bring it down this way it feeds all
the other organisms and gives them
ability to actually compete so now we
have a more diverse community and this
could be really important for how our
earth is changing with climate change
okay now moving into a completely
different environment we're leaving the
cold the frigid anoxic environment now
we're moving to the lush puerto rican
rain forest
as you can imagine this is where we're
using our 13c so we have these luxury
foresters which are known to have this
high diversity and are critical for
storing carbon on our planet
but one thing a lot of people don't know
is that the rain forests have these
crazy redox conditions in the soil where
you can get this this
downpour that just floods the soils
and these microbes are highly diverse
here so what is going on how are they
surviving this they go through periods
where there's oxygen and then no oxygen
and they have to be able to respond and
survive that we wanted to know how are
they surviving and who's active is it
are they constantly dying and other ones
are emerging are viruses active and more
importantly how does this redux
condition the switching between oxic and
anoxic environment affect the fate of
the organic carbon there are we is it
helping store carbon or is it causing a
problem releasing this carbon
so we set up a treatment experiment
where we had four different treatments
we had octic the whole time and oxygen
the whole time a high frequency switch
every four days and this lower frequency
shift of four and eight days to mimic
rain patterns of the area
so this is where we used a 13c enriched
plant biomass and we incubated with soil
over 44 days and remember we're not
we're not looking for all active
organisms specifically looking at the
organisms and viruses that are part of
breaking down this plant biomass and the
fate of this biomass being released in
its atmosphere or stored in the soil
so we were able to maintain this kind of
head space of oxic or an optic using a
nitrogen gas
and then we incubated for 44 days so
here we also wanted to compare are we
actually getting increased
resolution on our viruses bacteria by
teasing apart the active versus the
inactive so we did a comparative study
we took 10 traditional metagenomes which
i call bulk soil metagenomes and then we
had 85 stip fractionated metagenomes and
this is where we teased apart heavy
fractions and fractions then compare
them
the main takeaway from this is if you
think about it in comparison to our
arctic samples the diversity was so much
higher here
we had 64 active or sorry 46 active
bacteria before here we had 326 and that
was just looking at the carbon there
were other ones that didn't eat didn't
care about breaking down the plant
biomass
and these bacteria spanned 20 different
phyla so this huge diversity
we also had 640 viral populations almost
double compared to our last one and this
is just looking at the carbon only
when we compared our sip fractionated to
our traditional metagenomes we see that
we did increase the resolution on the
viruses because when we compare them we
got about seven percent more
viral population so we increased our
diversity that we captured
now i want you to focus on this figure
here let me help you break it down
because i know these he max can get
crazy so let's focus on the one on the
left at the top i have the black ones
these are kind of my bulk samples and
then in blue i have my control samples
this is just regular plant biomass and
then the red at the bottom this is the
13c rich plant biomass and what i want
your eyes to see is if you see white
there's no abundance that's a viral
population that wasn't doing anything
you see some orange there's a viral
population there it's doing something
you see green not only is there a viral
population there but it's taken off it's
killing its house it's redirecting its
metabolism it's influencing the
environment so that's what we care about
i also have zoomed in on the figure on
the right just the active ones because
this is the ones we really care about
right these are the ones that are
controlling the carbon right now
so you'll see that in the oxic we had
the most each line is the viral
population we had the highest diversity
of viral populations and this decreased
along the redox gradient so when there
was anoxic and there's less oxygen
there's less viruses and if you think
about it that makes sense when you're a
virus when you're taking up your house
you either want to kill it and make more
progeny viruses you're like oh my babies
or you want to lie low in it and you
want it to become strong and efficient
so it can survive this hard time before
you make your babies later so what you
want to do is you want to be able to use
a fish
earth that kind of the fastest the
strongest metabolism arguably
is oxygenated metabolism
then if you look at the anoxic
environment you'll see we have these
green ones remember i said that was
important these are viruses that are
highly abundant so even though we have
less viruses in that anoxic in the no
oxygen soils they're highly abundant so
we have things
we have these viruses that were able to
feel this niche space that others
couldn't
and they're taking off they're loving it
they're living their life to their
fullest they're happy so this is
actually a paper that we're still
developing and we're really trying to
look how are these viruses different how
are they dealing with this metabolism
that doesn't require oxygen and that's
going to be critical to look at what
genes are using you doing
and
viruses to the bacterial host we knew
which ones were involved with plant
biomass but are they only affecting the
plant degradation by killing hosts and
preventing them from breaking down the
biomass or are they doing other things
so we surveyed their genomes and we
found that they actually encoded genes
that when they infect the host they're
helping the host break down the plant
biomass and this is a reoccurring story
that we're finding in soils
typically in in the oceans you don't see
these
glycoside hydrolases to help break down
biomass but install
[Music]
those see more and more of these genes
that viruses are carrying to help the
host so they're having this roles in
carbon cycling that we just don't know
the whole story on
okay i'm moving on to my ldrd work so at
a national lab you can get research
funded and what's called an ldrd this is
lab directed research and development
and this is something i love about
working at a national lab these are
called high risk high reward studies
this would be
you you spit ball an idea to a friend
and they're like oh that sounds crazy i
feel like it would fail that's what they
want to fund here they want a high risk
high reward you dream something big and
it's either going to be amazing or
you're you're it's going to fail but
you're going to learn something from
that failure and that's what i got
funded and that's what i've been working
on and that's what i'm going to tell you
about right now
okay so i'm stepping back we talked
about metagenome before i just want to
remind you from the metagenomes we're
getting this low resolution on viruses
so i set up this experiment using a
grassland soil because there we found
out recently that they could be super
important for carbon storage by having
these long roots so we took a grassland
soil and we had four different
treatments we either had our water or we
had our heavy water to look at the
active ones and we added we added
phosphate because we thought you know
viruses use a lot of phosphorus when
they make their capsids so we're
wondering if it's critical for infection
so we had some treatments we added that
we also wanted to know how these viruses
changed
in this how they affected the ecosystem
and themselves how they changed over
time so we sampled over the course of a
month
before we're adding the water and after
adding the water
and what's important here
uh if you if you're not from california
like i originally wasn't you don't
understand this that the whole summer
there is no rainfall it's great for
tourism but you would think it sucks for
the organisms in the soil how do they
survive
half the year with no water so they have
no water for half the year and then come
to the fall they have the first rainfall
you get this birch effect you get water
being added and all these organisms come
to life and so much of the carbon is
lost after that first rain event because
we're now getting substrates as
organisms to reactivate so this is what
i want to study so we're adding the
water here to these dry soils to really
see what's going on here
but it wasn't just metagenomics i wanted
to do i spent my whole phd
optimizing methods for what we call
biomes or viral targeted metagenomes and
as you can see from the figure here it's
a multi-step process where we take soil
we wash it with different buffers and we
physically separate by size
fractionation typically a 0.2 or 0.5
micron filter to get things a virus size
out of the soil and then we sequence
that
so i can i'm showing here visually
comparing the circles we get so much
more information on the viruses from the
spiral we also
funny enough get information on ultra
small bacteria and archaea as well so
it's just it's a really cool technique
and so the con about this though is if
you just take a biorum you're not
necessarily getting all the hosts unless
of the ultra small host you kind of want
to take both if you want to know if you
want to relate viruses back to the
ecosystem level consequences from
mitigating their hosts
on top of this though we wanted to take
a meta transcriptome and this is going
to be looking at all the rna from the
soils and this is important because
there's all these viruses out there
there aren't a virus is the only
biological entity that we know can have
double-stranded and single-stranded dna
or rna some can reverse back and forth
between that as well so we needed to get
the rna as well to look at these viruses
finally something that we kind of hit on
here and invented some methods for is we
call this e-dna metagenome so in the
past it's been called ancient dna relic
dna degraded dna blah blah blah
or environmental dna or exogenous dna so
this is just dna that is in the
environment and i wanted to see okay if
we have dna environment
what what's its origin what's its
function is it being used in biofilms is
it coming from organisms dying are other
organisms eating is it a buffet what's
happening
and by taking all these methods together
we can get a better understanding of the
whole virus here from all these
different components
okay so
related back to edna we've only gotten
into a little bit of data so it's
preliminary but i wanted to share some
of it with you so in this figure i have
our time points the t-zero is pre-wet up
and then we have one week two weeks and
three weeks after we added our water and
the white scale we have the log scale
right so huge changes between the amount
of e-dna we're seeing so the t-zero we
have a lot of e-dna so which means if
you're taking a meta genome you're also
seeing dna not from inactive organisms
but also not even inactive in organisms
at all just in the environment so what's
going on there
okay oh it accumulates over the dry
summer this is my leading theory so far
as i'm investigating
and then we have this downshift so
what's going on okay well we added water
organisms now have this water to use to
fuel their metabolism and this dna is
juicy they're hungry these are
cheeseburgers or salads if you're
vegetarian they're loving it they're
like no no no no so the eat dna is
dropping the microbial populations are
increasing and we see that we see the
number of microbial populations and
their vitamins increasing
then we kind of have 11 alphabet and we
have viruses killing microbes so we have
the microbial populations dropping we
have a little bit more of e-dna going
into the environment so viruses are
contributing to the e-dna environment
not by killing the host in their
necromancer going out there
but then we see maybe the community
stabilizing where we have this arms race
where viruses are killing micro bringing
the population down that micro becomes
resistant to the virus so then it can
start increasing so we kind of get this
leveling of the e-dna in the
environment and when we actually compare
where is this edna coming from so on
this other figure i have here i have our
viral populations on the y-axis and i
have a microbial populations on x-axis
and then the dots represent
who does the edna belong to and the
majority of it if you look at our line
that i provided for you actually belongs
to the microbes so they're coming from
these microbes that are being killed or
the microbes could be exuding it to
build biofilms and survive
okay so i want to make sure i have
enough time to give everyone questions
but one last thing i wanted to talk
about before going into my astrobiology
shout outs is i want to talk about other
ways besides bioinformatics and omics
that you can look at viruses and look at
detection of life
so nanosims which is nanoscale secondary
ion mass spectroscopy this is where we
can use a beam to destroy
a substrate a particle something and we
reconstruct it into a picture so we've
been pushing to be able to look at
viruses this way and what's cool is we
can have nano sims on a rover to go
somewhere else and we can actually see
things that are alive or that we
consider alive
um so i have here some tem images where
we've been purifying to look at viruses
so we have this sifuvir day it's a cut
ovaries it's a double-stranded dna
bacteriophage that we were able to see
with the nanostims and then we are on
team and then we put on the nano sims on
the top right we've been able to see
these other cool filamentous um viruses
these really cool ones
and
the specialty about seeing something
within anderson's is you can physically
see it so you know it's there it's not
just a dot or something that we have to
infer you're seeing it that it's there
but also we can add in isotopes to
actually see if it's active so here we
use the 13c so we know where carbon's
incorporated in the virus and we know
that the virus is active as well so you
may have heard about the viking missions
in the past we've come so far since then
so this is exciting stuff to think about
for the future
okay so my quick shout outs
is that we really wanted to push viruses
and astrobiology and really get
astrobiology you don't have to be
someone who studies viruses to get into
it there's no correct or direct path to
be an astrobiologist if you study life
in any form whether it's physics
chemistry or biology you can become an
astrologer to care about the questions
you're asking
so we did a white paper to increase
awareness and funding for viruses and
that's available now if you want to go
to the link
and this is really just how to
incorporate viruses into astrobiology
and we had questions that we asked and
what was really cool is i got to work
with penny boston which was the former
head of the nasa astrology institute i'm
ken stedman who is at portland state
university and my good friend catherine
bywaters
we also
so that was already published we also
wanted to change our framing and get
other people to be excited about
astrobiology as well so the first one is
everything viruses viruses are cool
usually viruses as well our second one
which i have in the bottom which we're
calling viruses as modulators of
cellular metabolism this is specifically
how we can use viruses
for long-term space travel or short-term
space travel and what are the effects on
human beings that of viruses or even on
keeping our ecosystem viruses infect
plants so how do viruses affect plants
in space viruses and technology that
we're using to clean up our waste or
make food they also affect us or if we
come back we need to understand this
viruses are also really small and
they've been detected even in our clean
rooms so we also have to think about
viruses for planetary protection as well
so that's one that we submitted last
fall and so hopefully to be published
this year so just keep an eye out for
that
i also wanted to point out that in 2019
nai funded our astrovirology workshop
without walls this is a free two-day
event that we did spaced out over two
parts of the day to really engage the
whole world so i have a map here of
everyone that was active during it but
i've had many people from other
countries reach out to me that was
helpful so both of them are available on
youtube you can watch the whole thing
the questions everything is there we've
tried to organize into two themes but
everything's about viruses on earth and
the potential for space and how viruses
can have all this different nucleic acid
so i implore you to please check it out
um email me if you have questions i'd
love to get feedback on it hopefully we
can do more workshops like that in the
future
uh the final thing i want to say is
we're going to abs icon this may
grandson he's going to be there i'm
going to be there as well please come
see us please join our session we have
two amazing speakers dr rachel whitaker
and olivia negro and we're talking about
viruses everything viruses and what's
cool is at the end of the
session we're going to have kind of a
town hall with all the speakers to
really discuss where the field is going
what are questions you have how you get
in the field where do we need to push to
really get people to start thinking
about viruses
whether you consider them or live or not
is semantics they are integral to life
as far as we know they've been here
since life if not before life so when
we're looking for life why not look for
the most abundant thing that's related
to life the most abundant biological
entity which are viruses
with that i just want to acknowledge
the diverse teams i'm working with at
berkeley jgi
lawrence um lawrence berkeley national
lab once livermore national lab uh we
have our science focus area grant that
i'm working on um i also want to
do fun talk about funding from
uh our ldrd these hybrids however work
that have really pushed our science and
have been foundational for really
understanding viruses in all ecosystems
i also would just want to do a land
acknowledgement for where our studies
are taking place and the people who took
care of those lands before we got there
and are taking care of him now so we
appreciate that
um and then i want to end the question
so here i have uh a nice diagram that
penny boston made about you know viruses
are not considered life sometimes
they're not incorporated into the tree
of life because we use a marker gene
that viruses don't have but viruses
affect all life viruses even in fact
viruses so we need to be thinking small
and thinking viral
and with that i'll take questions
great thank you so much dr trouble that
was an amazing speech
okay so we have a few questions for you
um number one was such a small
proportion of reeds mapped to viruses
how do you know of the actual sequences
found with low coverage
that is a great question so
let's take a metagenome and let's say
you have a hundred percent of your data
this is the data you get these are what
we're going to call our reads
so less than two percent go to viruses
but if you actually look at a
traditional soul imagine them depending
on where it's from and how they're doing
it
not all those other reads are going to
be used either right
i said two percent less than two percent
of the assembled rate so we have all
these the majority of reads actually not
being used because life is so diverse
and so complex that we just can't even
tease it apart
so then we're just looking at data that
we can assemble so the data that we are
aware of okay so looking at this usable
data
how do we know
if something's virus enough it has low
coverage well we need to increase our
coverage so that was why i traditionally
pushed for the vyram approach and really
looking at the biomes and then you're
saying for those one few viruses that we
get from the metagenome how do we know
that those have coverage well that's
that's what's tricky is
in a metagenome you're also getting host
right so a virus can be integrated into
a host
when it's integrating a host if that
host is highly abundant every time its
genome is duplicated the viruses genome
is also duplicated so if the host is
highly abundant the virus is also highly
abundant so when i said less than two
percent go to viruses
the ones that do go to viruses go to
those highly abundant viruses
so we get low diversity
but we get high coverage or relatively
high coverage of them now you're right
though it's it's hard
especially with variance
in either our technology or that just
exists within populations how do we know
what is and what isn't so a lot of times
we get incomplete genomes where we're
just recovering the parts of the genome
that have a lot of coverage or we use
great tools out there um simon roon made
virus order which is one of my favorites
and now there's viewer sorter too they
really look for hallmark genes or parts
that relate to a virus like strand bias
or short genes to really say hey this is
a virus and it gives you confidence and
rules with that as well
um
but yeah where it to really increase the
resolution of viruses you have to
decrease the complexity of the sample i
had tried virums before i'm now using
stable isotope probing there's so many
other methods out there that we can push
to really increase our resolution on
viruses there's now single cell genomics
there's microfluidics being used
arguably you could
use a tem to try to look at part of a
sample i mean there there's so many
different ways we can do and i hope that
answers your question
yes thank you
um the next question is has there been
any evidence to suggest that there are
archaea that associate with viruses and
soils
oh absolutely yeah sorry
it seems biased here that i'm like
bacteria bacteria bacteria
um i just want to step back and say
most of the viruses we see in soils are
bacteriophage which are viruses that
infect bacteria and most of them are
double-stranded dna viruses
and if you think about metagenomics in
our sequencing we were set up to look at
what we thought of his life so this is
humans plants fungi bacteria they have
double-stranded dna genomes
so our sequencing technology is set up
for that so it's no chance that like
this is why we do it this is why we have
double stranded dna viruses right this
is why we can easily see them or easily
um
so
there are ways out there which you can
start to get a single strand of dna
viruses i had published some papers that
way we have to really think about when
we're prepping our samples for
sequencing and thinking about that
single stranded dna or you know if
you're thinking about relicting or
ancient dna the highly rated dna is also
usually single stranded so if you think
about them as the same single stranded
dna viruses in line with e-dna you kind
of are going to find methods to help you
get that
finding rna in environments is really
difficult so there hasn't been a lot of
work with meta transcriptomes and i've
been trying to push that others have as
well um
this one day we're gonna get an rna
viral to really look at the encapsulated
rna viruses if they are the majority out
there
so
yeah i i i know can you rephrase the
question or say it again so i can make
sure i answered it
yeah just asking about um
like archaea associated with our systems
so sorry everything was set up towards
bacteriophage so for archaea they also
have viruses but
what we know about viruses that largely
come from isolates and we can eat more
easily grow bacteria compared to arctica
so we also have more isolates on viruses
and bad bacteria so we know more about
them so i talked about veer sorter
before well it looks for enrichment of
genes for caudal virales which are
bacteriophage so they also push towards
archaeal or sorry bacterial viruses
we have found some great archaeal
viruses um ken stedman has done it in
hot springs which are not soils but you
get some cool lemon shaped ones
um we know they exist in swirls there
are some previous papers um i'm trying
to think of the names right now there
are that we know that they're there
why we don't see them as much
people have said oh archaea have
more crispers or less crispers you've
heard of both ways they they're less
abundant so viruses don't care about
them
i really just think it's it's our
sampling um they are there but we know
very little about them especially in
soils as you probably know that if we're
going to find them it's usually in hot
springs or these other aquatic
environments
sorry i hope i can answer that answer
your question but there's not much more
i can give you on that
yes definitely no thank you
um okay so i have one more question for
you
would you consider virus to be life's
fail-safe against mass extinction or are
there more of an intermediate step that
have found a new way to propagate
so let me make sure i got this right the
failsafe against mass extinction in
terms of the virus controlling these
populations to make sure everyone else
has a fair share
um so if i think of it in that way
i would say yes and no i mean i don't
think anything's engineered that way i
think you have
a biological entity that is selfish it
wants to replicate so it goes after the
most food
if you had a buffet out
that maybe that's not the best
comparison but because
yeah
you you're more likely to go where
there's resources so i guess a better
comparison would be if you knew you had
to survive somewhere for three days and
we had
a beach that was barren or desert land
and then you had a condo here with all
the amenities you would choose a condo
with the amenities because you want to
make sure you're caring for your progeny
your offspring you want to make sure
they're still going so viruses i think
have just evolved to to kill the most
abundant i don't know if it is a way for
nature to control itself
i mean there's the gaia hypothesis is
you know it's self-regulating this this
giant mega ecosystem
um and if you want to go down the road
i could agree with you that viruses are
doing a good job at keeping diversity at
regulating that now what's tricky though
is
they don't do it alone right the hosts
have to adapt to survive it was just up
to the viruses they would kill and make
a population go extinct right and in
cases where we have like phage therapy
that's kind of the goal we're trying to
get a population to go extinct so we're
also relying on the host to be able to
evolve to out-compete it so is that the
host that's the failsafe that it learned
its lessons coming back if we're gonna
personify it
i i don't know and then when it i think
you're leading to when it comes to
humans that gets more tricky because we
met a conjugate we can think about
thinking we're self-aware
and we can change our actions so unlike
this microbe that that has to evolve
genetically to survive
we
can
take stances where we can fend off the
virus right where we can stop the thing
that's trying to control us so there's
there's so many different ways i don't
want to go too far down that rabbit hole
but i know what you're thinking and i
don't think life is malicious i think
everything is trying to do its best and
the virus itself wants to propagate and
it wants to keep itself happy so it's
going where the most resources are
definitely okay thank you very much of
course well that was again a great talk
by dr trouble